[Music]
the reception to the show has been
unprecedented and beyond anything we
could have imagined Elisabeth Moss has
seemingly struck TV gold again you girls
will serve the leaders and their barren
wives
you will bear children for them
the actress stars in the new Hulu series
The Handmaid's Tale which has already
been picked up for a second season and
is sparking tons of Emmy buzz I want to
go back and make another season like I
want to play the character again and so
for us as cheesy as it might sound that
is actually the most important thing I
just want people to enjoy the show and I
just want people to to watch it and get
what I got from it listen to me
and blessed her those who suffer for the
cause of righteousness moss please
offered the handmaid a woman whose
rights have been stripped away from her
a topic she says she knows a thing or
two about oh gosh I know nothing about
women's rights being taken away from
them I think that we as women in this
day and age in this country can
definitely identify with that idea so it
wasn't unfortunately it wasn't too much
of a leap for me we only wanted to make
the world better better better never
means better for everyone
[Music]
you